miami trying to sweep
the season series against the los
angeles lakers
haven't swept the lakers in a regular
season since the 14-15 season
and that's an exclamation point from all
the depots grabbing at his knee
after that that was uh
yeah was that wardrobe driven or
something
tugged at him we'll see yeah he's
limping he's not in good shape here
chris
oh the depot's hurt they need a timeout
they need a whistle and they get it
and oladipo is on his way out ouch
a little surprised because he had such a
clear lane but he kind of stumbles right
there and
you see how he comes down and he feels
it while he's in the air and if you're a
heat fan
you're just making sure you're sending
some well wishes as he walks
to the back and if you are a laker guard
you take advantage trying to get to the
paint chris just watching victor oladipo
leave the floor right there you feel for
him with his injury history and that
brutal injury just a few years ago man i
know there is major concern with him and
the miami heat
yeah you never want to see especially a
new player go through any type of just a
little twinge in his
knee or leg especially an athletic
player that
really uses athletic ability to force
his will on both ends of the floor so
you hope that he's okay
but if you're miami heat you're saying
next guy up and if you're the lakers
you're saying let's take
advantage of one of their best players
being out but look at this little
that little stumble right there with the
right foot i'm not a doctor i'm not
trying to guess but having played this
game i know where the awkwardness comes
in and how you can hurt yourself
and right there that was not a normal
gate nor cadence
and it seems like that may have been
where he just uh
irritated something hopefully i hope
that's all it is
yes eric spoelstra
will bring hero back on the floor